you put in rejects what kind of like how
birds of prey should have ended Harley
Quinn his evideo excited to check this
out because of the overwhelming positive
response this movie got everyone loves
this we're like the only two people on
the internet who did not like this movie
so it's pretty surprising that we're
actually doing this maybe this will
convince us that if they did this way we
might have actually liked the movie
let's go into it
[Music]
as do best
[Music]
harley quinn and the birds don't bow
listened or not I had to drive in but
this book took it from me because he
didn't trust me carrying it why would
you do that why would you lie I'm going
to ask
[Music]
[Music]
no private text messages
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
as great as great
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
a plus
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
hell yeah that's great Chris actually
really admired the tone and pacing of
this specific one a lot of times more
fast paced you usually have especially
you know with how heavy desert videos
now is the kind of likens back a little
bit more to the older days where it was
pretty much just focused on the one
segment of how it should have ended
because he had like maple it with just
three other scenes yeah you look right
there a couple bits but most part you
just had that one ending but those bits
were kind of making fun of scenes and
not even another version of how it could
have ended in that early on there I was
poke some holes yeah that like things
might have ended differently had they
gone this yeah and they're also just
especially like the cell phone no yeah
it's true there's something that drives
me nuts in movies a lot of the time I
know but in this movie I was like I
don't really care
yeah the actual buyout of it in the film
itself fun to see that they brought back
like their version of Batman their
version of Arthur flex Joker actually
led to like the biggest laughs were not
really the spoofing of the scenes in it
themselves but including their own
versions of how it should have ended
characters in here really made it click
that because I'm Batman line when he
first showed up was such a big laugh for
me and it was such an unexpected moment
to occur yeah but brilliant in terms of
the hizzy world
yeah and as I love the way that moment
was executed I don't remember I watched
it on my own time didn't react to it I
think you did that by herself but the
house should have entered at the Joker I
don't remember what their hearts
reflection played out like I love how
this is following the I don't give a
[ __ ] about life version of Arthur Fleck
character well yeah it was funny because
when he showed up I was like I you know
not that they're like a perfect match
but I can see them getting along a whole
lot better than the Joker Harley Quinn
well the balance of them you do put into
that light of you have this more
reserved version of an Arthur Fleck kind
of Joker and then you have the really
kinetic version of Harley Quinn yeah
there is this weird thing where actually
they would balance each other out didn't
I bet that like he would probably like
actually learn to like her he would
probably just like care a lot about her
if any of that like that's a plot line
is to be believed no like he clearly
wants somebody to love and take care of
and I thought that was such a brilliant
beat of when she's laughing and then
Arthur reflect doesn't know how to
respond and he just goes into his like
uncomfortable laugh at the movie
perfectly on pity yeah knowing your
characters in the movies they came in
the timing and rhythm of that was
absolutely perfect
and watching Batman hit on all these
girls I mean there's this part of this
that makes sense this is Gotham yeah
yeah yeah he's bound to appear right at
some point during this I mean I think in
terms of movie version yeah you don't
want that but in terms of like some
logic here like show up at some point
right yeah yeah I mean him hitting on
the girls was like a hilarious moment
they've really fleshed out this Batman
character for the hizzy world he's not
exactly Will Arnett's version of the
Lego Batman movie but this version came
before that if anything yeah well our
net version ate some of this version oh
yeah I can count on the fact that his II
just the meme of embedment and all that
stuff has to have seeped into the
cultural consciousness enough that it
had influence on Lego Batman yeah at the
very very least I don't even recall the
exact connection with Huntress in the
comics with Batman was actually my first
introduction to birds of prey
was the CW show which was shortly lived
and in that version the hunters
character was the daughter of Batman and
Catwoman but I don't think that's how it
is in the current edition but I liked
how this sketch decided a link-up
Heather paths are kind of similar to
each other yeah it's making of a stretch
when he's going to Renee Montoya be like
hey the cops don't like us either yeah I
just love that and then finally he gets
down and there's nothing in common with
the Black Canary
I thought there would be something there
with some bait in here with about
Cassandra Cain considering Cassandra
Caden is Batgirl more than just pointing
it out or something like that like
actually seeing them together like later
or in the Batcave all right guys hey Z
thanks again for putting together
another it is a much-needed laughs this
morning thank you guys for watching and
subscribe to Z if you haven't done so
already subscribe but the real rejects
click that notification bell last but
not least
TJ trakis I can see your daughter going
through exactly the situations of all of
the main three birds of prey characters
maybe even more than them you know I
imagine that at some point you're bound
to get murdered just knowing your
personality you're bound to get murdered
so first she's gonna inherit a bunch of
money she's gonna have a little bit of
Huntress attitude inside of her a little
bit of Elena Bertinelli inside of her as
she's going into the world she might
want to take down the right path do do
good by her mom and do the right thing
and they go down the Renee Montoya path
but of course she's a little bit
rebellious just like you so she's not
gonna be liked in the police department
so she's gonna quit and try to do things
take the law into her own hands by
becoming a singer like Deana Lance
that's not gonna pan out so well so
she's gonna turn to love and find
someone else of the criminal of sorts
and become a bit of a Harley Quinn and
along the way she's gonna swallow a
diamond and develop an intense love for
puddin and you can be proud of yourself
because this is the legacy you've left
behind TJ you've ruined your daughter's
life congratulations I would you I hope
you're doing well brother